عندما كان أه ينظر حول غرفة
بدا أنه كان يبحث عن أهداف
لإلحاق الأذى بأشخاص
[موسيقى]
أجنبية [
موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
أدركت
أنني بحاجة إلى إخراج السلاح منه
وأحتاج إلى نزع سلاحه
كان من الممكن أن يموت هو أو أي شخص آخر
عندما حصلت على الشجاعة ، فاندفعت
إليه بكلتا يدي
وأمسكت بالسلاح وكنا
نكافح في
الردهة
في محاولة لإبعاد هذا السلاح عن
بعضنا البعض كان يضربني على وجهي
ضربت مؤخرة رأسي
كنت أحاول استخدام مرفقي
لفصل البندقية عنه مما خلق
بعض المسافة
أخيرًا في وقت ما تمكنت من سحب
البندقية بعيدًا عنه
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
[موسيقى] أجنبية
كنت مرتجفًا كنت أرتجف
طوال الليل
لم أصدق ما حدث
بعد الاستيقاظ ، لقد لاحظت وجود
كدمات في جميع أنحاء جسدي يعاني وجهي من
كدمة في الأنف وظهر
رأسي يعاني من بعض الكدمات أستطيع  لا
أعتقد أن هذا يمكن أن يحدث
[موسيقى]
أجنبية